well white island also known as bokhari
is in the Bay of Plenty of New Zealand's
East Coast and is the country's most
active cone volcano in November
government scientists issued warnings of
increased activity on the
privately-owned
island on December the 3rd scientists
raised the alert from 1 to 2 and want
the volcano may be entering a period
where erupted activity is more likely
than normal
adding that the current level of
activity does not pose a direct hazard
to visitors but today the volcano
erupted just after 2 p.m. local time has
been described by experts as a
throat-clearing eruption of volcanic gas
and ash his skies Tom Cheshire a tower
of ash and smoke 12,000 feet high
this is the terror of the eruption of
white island taken by a tourist who'd
been standing on the edge of the crater
just half an hour earlier at this stage
we can confirm that amongst those
currently listed as missing or injured
New Zealanders who were part of the Tor
operation and tourists from Australia
the United States the United Kingdom
China and Malaysia that is to the best
of our knowledge to those who have lost
or are missing family and friends we
share in your understandable grief at
this moment in time and in your sorrow
your loved ones stood alongside Kiwis
who are hosting you here and we grieve
with you and we grieve with them the
volcano erupted at 11 past 2:00 in the
afternoon when Ireland is about 30 miles
of the coast of New Zealand's North
Island and a fleet of helicopters was
quickly dispatched they evacuated 23
people and brought them back to
hospitals on the mainland
many were treated for burn injuries and
those who've been confirmed dead were
among the rescued but others did not
make it off the island emergency workers
could not search the volcano itself
because of the unsafe conditions but
aerial reconnaissance has confirmed the
word
pilot they went out the year in spent
about 45 minutes it is provided a pretty
good indication that we do not believe
anybody else he survived that explosion
we also had the Eagle helicopter up
there as well for a considerable period
of time and we could to keep no signs of
life
we understand dozens of tourists were on
a trip to the island from the ovation of
the Seas cruise ship despite warnings of
an increase in volcanic activity issued
in November and December this image
taken ten minutes before the eruption
from a webcam inside the volcano so it's
the tiny figures of people on a tour
around the crater itself this one taken
just one minute before appears to show
them heading away any of the tourists on
the island would have had no one into
this whatsoever if you were far away
from the crater you would have seen the
the eruption happen if you were in the
crater you would have just found
yourself within it this would have been
an immediate eruption that happened kind
of beneath your feet or or next to you
there would have been perhaps a small
bit of rumbling but no more than a
second or two no time for evacuation in
this situation in one instant this
popular tourist site turned into a
disaster zone the search and recovery
operation will continue today after that
authorities must answer the question of
whether visitors should ever have been
allowed in harm's way
Tom Cheshire sky hazel